hello I'm at Conway welcome to my study
and I wanted to give you a bit of an
update on how the economy is doing been
a lot of focus and I've certainly been
spending all the time looking at their
grisly depressing news on health and
what's going on there but of course
there is an economic side to this as
well and in a way the big focus over the
course of the coming month is good about
it I'm gonna be about the economy rather
than being about health because we're
starting to see a real impact now on
many of our jobs and what we've got and
the reason why when it's talk to you is
what we've starting to see is some
evidence of just where it is hitting the
economy and what it means for the rest
of us and also just how vast some of
these schemes these government schemes
have been we've just got numbers out for
the Treasury on that it's kind of
there's some interesting stuff in there
but first of all you'll probably
remember like the facility of my first
interaction with this Cobra 19 crisis
actually wasn't about health it was
about Marcus because Marcus started to
tumble early on and what's happened
since then we'll have a look at what's
happened to share prices over the course
of the past six months
this chart shows you it you know there
was a very big fall one of the biggest
sports we have ever seen in share prices
there's my arrow to show how about it
was that was one of the worst Falls
actually over that month since the South
Sea Bubble in the early 18th century so
enormous for there but what's been
interesting actually is that markets
have really recovered a lot of ground
since then less so in the UK since the
first sea 100 and that the Dow Jones in
the SP and the Nasdaq er up two or got
up to more or less where they were at
the start of the year but just in the
last day in the last 24 hours we've seen
a bit of a fall down by kinda three 4%
in the UK and similar kind of amounts if
not more in wall street there are
concerns just you know this stuff is
nebulous but no concerns obviously about
the risk of a second wave so investors
out there getting a bit concerned again
get any concern and I suppose it's not
surprising given that a lot of the
economic news at the moment is quite bad
there has been this big question about
you know after the kind of life-support
system that has been
for the economy so the furlough scheme
and I'll get onto some of the ninja
numbers we have on that in a moment do
those jobs come back or do employers
just cut them particularly in certain
sectors like aviation and where they've
been really affected by this and I'm
afraid some of the news in Italy has
been very bad so we've had jobs numbers
job losses actually announced by
Centrica so they've announced five five
thousand job losses in the UK that's
that's kind of a quarter of their
workforce Johnson Matthey 2,500 jobs
there and Bombardier 600 jobs that but I
said northern I have a very big employer
in Northern Ireland Bombardier so those
are not by any means good news and when
you have a look at their kind of state
of the economy the concern is there may
well be more job losses and the bad news
is kind of yet to come what we've got
today from the Treasury is for the first
time they released details on the kinds
of jobs that have been covered by the
furlough scheme so we know that a lot of
people have been put on to furlough
they've had their wages paid by the
state
we know that's kind of getting towards
10 million particularly includes
self-employed people but what we didn't
really know is what the set is there and
we had a hunch they might be in things
like restaurants and retail but we
didn't know for sure now finally we have
the number so we have this table you
probably read it there there's lots of
interesting details though and one thing
I was struck by if we kind of zoom into
it and this is not the most important
thing I know in the world but just look
at this it's once including all these
other things like retail they were also
included this domestic employers it
turns out actually there have been six
thousand people I guess families around
the country who have used the furlough
scheme to support whether it's their
cleaner or nannies it has been used 15
million pounds that has cost the
taxpayer the Treasury perhaps keen to
underline the furlough scheme hasn't
just been about big companies it's also
been helping out people back home but as
I say the big impact is probably the
companies that you would imagine what
I've done is I've taken all of these
numbers here if the number of that's the
number of people a lot of jobs and their
employees number
of course and I've done it as a
percentage of workforce so you get a
sense by sector about how much they've
been effective and it's what it's more
or less as you'd expect so have a look
at this you've got perhaps most
obviously you know food and
accommodation down at the bottom they're
getting towards sixty percent of all
jobs in restaurants and hotels have been
furlough
probably not a surprise to you but none
and that's on the basis I just say us on
the basis of the employment numbers kind
of a year or so ago so you're talking
about the vast majority of people within
restaurants and hotels in further retail
as well again won't surprise you but
that's that's kind of about 50 percent
or so of retail people working retail
that's being furloughed but construction
you know this is the interesting thing
manufacturing and construction
particularly construction two industries
the word really supposed to you know
shut down in the way that other parts of
the economy did you know a lot of people
speculation about it at the time but
construction people were supposed to be
able to carry on working particularly in
building sites in the open air but
actually you know getting on getting
towards fifty percent of all
construction workers have been
furloughed so it is striking
you know how this scheme has been used
not just for parts of the economy that
were obviously locked down but actually
by parts of the economy that weren't
locked down at all in a big way
construction manufacturing to a lesser
extent as well property I guess you know
there's there's a fair few estate agents
who have been furloughed as a result of
the lockdown because they can't
necessarily do their jobs but it is just
striking looking at this and also what
we have is a regional breaker I want to
show you the regional breakdown its
striking just how far across the entire
economy this goes there's some sectors
that the barely affects is education
actually interestingly farming of
Finance you know a lot of people very
few jobs in finance and IT were
furloughed but really when you look
across the economy when you look across
the country it's hard to think of any
other policy that has been quite so
prevalent and widespread as well as this
one and you get a sense of that when you
kind of break it down by regions and
that's what I've done here
so this shows you different regions of
the UK for the West Midlands all the way
through to Wales and actually in a way
what's striking about this is not the
difference between them is the West
Midlands at the top and Wales at the
bottom there there's all the difference
between them but it's but the fact that
they are all kind of within this range
of about 21 22 to 25 percent of
employees getting furloughed across all
of the UK this has been a kind of
nationwide thing you know that's what
it's kind of interesting it has been a
real UK wide policy that has affected
many people around the country and the
most regions have been relatively
equally affected but actually what's
intriguing is when you break it down by
local authorities there are some
hotspots some places that have more
following than other places and let me
just show you a few of them because it's
you know it's rather interesting it
shows you some of the subtext of what's
been going on in this crisis so there
I've got a kind of heat map across it's
quite Britain this so unfortunate didn't
have break down further for Northern
Ireland of the employment numbers but
this shows you a breakdown and the the
more blue these areas are the more
people went into furlough as a
percentage of local employment and let
me just show you a few highlights
because obviously this is difficult to
see probably on the screen but let me
just zoom in a little bit there we will
go in to Crawley and in cruely actually
the of all local authorities around the
UK the most followed jobs as a
percentage of employees 33 getting over
34 percent of all the employees furlough
20,000 jobs for now what's significant
about Crawley its Gatwick you know
that's where Gatwick is and you're gonna
see a pattern here so cruelly Gatwick a
real hot spot for furlough let's move
and see the next biggest furlough sport
that was South Lakeland so the Lake
District a big tourist hotspot really
important tourism and obviously tourism
has been obliterated by covert 19 so
South Lake and you've got 33% of
employees furloughed and so you're
seeing kind of definite hotspots of
places where more people you know on
balance have been further
a third of workers in those two places
and more or less similar numbers in
pendel no penalties interesting because
I believe there's a Rolls Royce plant
around there so that's quite being quite
important and those words have said that
they followed a lot of their employees
this is about a third just under a third
in pendel and then constantly well
that's he Tory in Hounslow so you know
who there is there are some interesting
analogies here some interesting kind of
things when you look down forensically
and the numbers who's been affected and
when you kind of have a look at the
places which have been least effective
in terms of the least following well
again there's a pattern it's mostly in
London that you've seen the least follow
areas so Camden has the fewest
proportion of people who have taken all
the furlough scheme followed by
Kensington and Chelsea City of
Westminster and City of London also I
think between those two but it just
shows actually London areas did the
least bit amount of furloughing whereas
there was some regional divergence with
other places more affected and this is
this is I think the wari okay the
furlough scheme in a way is give
telegraphing where there might well be
job losses in the future you know some
of these companies they start off by
following then they take a call in a few
months time and then because fellow is
kind of essentially free money to
support your employees and then the job
loss has come later on so I suspect you
know the worry about this to me is
you're gonna see a kind of regional
element to the unemployment that comes
with some hotspots for unemployment in
the future and it looks like a lot of
them might well be outside of London so
again that regional divergence that
we've often talked about being an issue
there and now this is all really
expensive as you probably realize we're
starting also to get a sense of just how
expensive and it's not just when it
comes to the cost of kind of nannies and
housekeepers and and cleaners that the
total cost of the furlough scheme is now
kind of getting towards about 20 billion
pounds and then add on on top of that
the self employment scheme and you've
got a you're kind of well getting close
to 30 billion pounds in terms of the
total cost of this it's basically
you know you put it all together and
it's definitely kind of costing more
than the NHS which i think is not
something anyone had necessarily
countenanced and the worry is with that
that the longer this goes on the more
the risk of higher employer unemployment
in the future now that's the latest
update we are starting to get more of a
sense of where jobs have been furloughed
where jobs may be lost in the future the
story is not especially encouraging but
I think this is going to be the story of
the next six months it's a story of an
economy facing a very very deep
recession and we're now starting to see
the evidence of that